in the prize episodio pilota ammazzo ti
ammazzo ti ammazzo te lo giuro
cos'era happy car pooling skype
[Musica]
grazie grazie a tutti per tutti ragazzi
benvenuti qui sono video sono farisei e
ho fatto un update del mio cappello
bellissimo da angry birds che veramente
veramente figo primo livello epic fail
skill mio bar poveri nube che vengono
sempre magari se metto le cuffie come
dire posso ascoltare il cv da da cinque
anni non è che dicevi faida ieri nella 5
anni non mi ricordo di mettere epic fail
skill nuba ispe si prevista al calcio e
facciamo blu perché sono razzista con i
rossi sì però almeno rotola santo iddio
ok mi chiama almeno quello una costa dei
parchi il mina o però il senso di tutto
questo
infatti questi livelli sono veramente
una merda babbo guarda meno male i
trascorsi da solo zio bravo
riconosco la genialità del creatore di
questo livello semplicemente perché lo
sa lui che sono una merda si livello
ma era finto a ecco mi chiamo mi ha
preso per il culo seriamente cero che a
scatto sul serio il [ __ ] bottino
aspetta da fermi attimo botto film
questo uomo che hai fatto meglio
no mica uno fatto bene ce ne sono sempre
un miliardo porca eva 1 fatto bene c'è
spyphone hard core alla lo troviamo dopo
tanto lo troviamo tranquilli ragazzi ne
fanno troppi voglio farne uno fatto bene
per la prima volta nella vita ma vero e
serio
no perché ci metto sempre una vita
faresti mica di botto cipe non conclude
mai un cazzo
ma proprio niente ti può adesso per una
volta voglio provare a farlo bene
ragazzi non so se riesco problemi dopo
proviamo
innanzitutto il tuffo
allora c'è proprio la mamma che fa le
cose brutte in autostrada dies desio
desio
bene spike board swing folk dio santo
piroghe magari poteri scrive ma cos'è ma
cos'è bellissimo
l'ho presa noi non sono fatta a
prenderla ma va bene così
tutto storto sono tutto storto e restar
play valdaj ce la posso fare la gam lo
sento e è fighissimo se non ci fosse il
suo rumore di fondo fastidiosissimo che
dichiara ammazzerei creatore visto
livello sarebbe veramente un livello
fighissimo ci sono arrivato quanto
ancora tutto tutto nell'anno compreso il
cappello degli angry bird testi your
l'acne non dovete stare la mia fortuna
fu bello questo livello proprio bello
potevo scegliere una persona leggermente
più peso forma per passare in mezzo a
sti cosi porca eva un obeso scelto la
puoi fare zio ben e meno male che ios
che sfondi tutto con la tua massa perché
sono cugat se c'era la mia a volavo e
sono due hanno al terzo talmente sfigato
che non sono neanche caduto in mezzo
alle trappole fantastico bellissimo noi
fossimo loro quelli veramente
impossibili tipo questo
voleva morire sulle spine io perché non
mi hai fatto fare qual è il problema non
posso morire normalmente non posso
morire normalmente capisco no ma magari
girati dall'altra perfetto bene
l'espresso uguale all 8 il flip denis
mlg a dalla ferma nel suo video 1 adesso
io ok tutti calmi adesso io la butto su
quel coso rosso maledetto me ne frega un
cazzo
quel coso lì mlg lo devo centrare
maledetta di una forza non voleva
mandarlo lì però va bene
fermi no
kakà ce la devo fare ragazzi ce la posso
fare me lo sento no no no
porca vacca maida forza brutto ce la
posso fare ragazzi via feroce la faccio
melo 6 propri gusti stelle cost con un
anno un anno e mezzo
ok non me ne frega niente non me ne
frega devo riuscirci reagan devo
riuscirci fermi tutti allora voi di
schiaffi
ma gag ok va bene non era proprio quello
ok va benissimo che così a rock swing
ultra o dio mio
in occasione dell'ultima visita festival
fanno anche robbie buhl tra che culo
fermi se ci avessi le mani al posto dei
piedi potrei provare a fare una cosa
bella
non pensate male feticisti non ci riesco
sulla marca vacca è stato difficile
se notate sulla robe c'è scritto rope no
perché non lo capivo che era una rock
grazie avevano scritto perché non scrivi
cielo al posto del cielo così capisco
che che si tratta del cervello ma magari
invece scrive l'europa scrivi afferra
porca eva che sono un deficiente non me
lo ricordo mai gaga un ora per afferrare
st minieri lasciam perdere tutti i
problemi ai zio quanti problemi ai zio
ma perché non riesco a fare una roba del
centro che non esco a fare una roba del
genere no un'ora un'ora e mi raccomando
bravo nuova amica dicevano le braccia in
un rock swing brutto deficienti idiota
con un braccio solo riesco scommettete
non sapevo io no no no no mi fa male li
mi fa male li è grazie alla adesso
staccate mi raccomando prima che ci
avevo presso l'hotel o ultimo l'ultimo
tentativo a partire da adesso l'ultimo
giorno miglioro poi non lo faccio più
duro lo giuro l'ultima fa bowman deve
scendere il creatore di è più il caso di
fare l'ultima poi scende veramente mio
papà da torino e mi dice basta
ok ok non ci voleva tanto è sulla saper
fare quest'anno una rona cagata minchia
mio cugino di due anni a faceva baia fan
hardcore
non ho fatto bene facciamo pure un
ragazzo giusto perché bus power di chi è
partito lione non è uscito dallo schermo
ma perché quasi c'eravamo eravamo lì ok
provarli farlo un attimo giusto perché
io switch un attimo ecco lo sapevo è la
bici si aggiudica la vittoria va bene
così ma io switch e un attimo la visione
di su luke che per per vedere cosa sta
succedendo niente mi trovo morto in
tibet così che cari anche da morti sono
vicini ho fatto anche la rima ed isab
bench che cosa è successo o guarda luke
c'è un morto perché non avevo a fare una
partita di calcio che ne dici di testa
ecco ne sa niente particolare salve è lo
porto a casa lo porto a casa grazie
perché mi regalano l'argenteria quali
problemi ha visto gli occhi ci hanno
regalato delle spade ti piace ecco la
macchina la prendo io non ho ben capito
il perché ci sta
madonna come lo schivato salve sono
morto è noto sono molto seri ci siamo
ragazzi solito ce l'ho fatta credo è
fino a qua fino a sto punto sono andato
molto meglio poi non lo so
ok non erano lo sa che il pericolo erano
sì cosi dal dal cielo va bene
[Musica]
che bello quando lanci tuo figlio nel
water e va a sbattere contro un muro
invisibile proprio una soddisfazione
cazzo segway jump fit for a beat for bit
ma sii serio
cos'è ma non c'è la gravità e sto
livello è fighissimo
ma demachy storia allora siccome non mi
interessa è così no no no no è bravo un
po più a destra
bravissimo goduria
ma si sa mai perché è vabbè sempre un
film migliore di gravity non scherzo è
bellissimo gravità happy car pooling
scape
[Musica]
grazie grazie a tutti
allora ragazzi come ultima cosa voglio
vedere se scappare allora bottle si
chiama botto il botto suite qualsiasi 1
fatto bene questo ok riesco a fare
winner 1 ma ma è un buon inizio è un
buon inizio è un ottimo inizio
già sembra buttati giù figlio schifoso
barca era ok è riuscito a farne tre su
tre il quarto mi chiama è andato che
sfiga terminati ma come ti amo lo faccia
ma per farlo andare sotto
non ci voglio credere caserta è ma porca
maledetta schifosa quando era nel
giardino dell'eden porca maledetta eva
[Musica]
ragazzi basta basta basta basta basta
basta perché basta cioè non c'è verso
spero io vidi 700 ragazzi episodio
classe via migliore sull'argomento e mi
piace anche i vari social che come
ricaduta descrizione social city siate
ci vediamo al prossimo video la ragazza
[Musica]